Is it possible that all life on earth including
human life originated from alien DNA?
Hello fellow Alpha Centurians!
Ian here for DNews to talk about the meaning
of life, kinda.
Let’s cut to the chase: we have a pretty
good idea that life on Earth popped into being
around three and a half billion years ago.
Sure, back then, life wasn’t particularly
glamorous -- unless being a single-celled
prokaryote living in a pool of organic goo
is your idea of “glamor” -- but that’s
how we think our planet's biosphere began.
There is, however, a lot of debate surrounding
how life came to be and where life’s building
blocks REALLY came from.
Were all the prebiotic chemicals already here
on Earth, laid out like the ingredients to
a biological cake?
Or did these chemicals come from elsewhere?
A tantalizing clue recently came from Europe’s
Rosetta mission that has been orbiting Comet
67P for the past 2 years.
In addition to the incredible number of discoveries
Rosetta has made, the detection of the amino
acid, glycene in the comet’s coma -- basically
the dusty, gassy atmosphere surrounding the
comet -- has excited astrobiologists.
This is the second comet known to be carrying
the amino acid.
In 2004 it was found on comet Wild-2 (“Vilt-2”),
which is exciting because we know that glycene
is one of the essential building blocks for
life and we know that finding it in more than
one place isn’t a fluke.
Not only that, but Rosetta’s comet also
contains other compounds that form the building
blocks of life, including the element phosphorous
that is the backbone of DNA and RNA, reaffirming
comets as potential “seeds” for life on
planetary bodies.
So we have a pretty good idea that the ingredients
for life can be found anywhere and could be
transported to habitable worlds via comets.
But what if life ITSELF could be transplanted
from one planet to another?
This concept is known as “panspermia”
and it’s a hypothesis that really puts your
imagination into a spin.
For argument’s sake, let’s say life formed
on Earth first.
In the billions of years of evolution, Earth
has been hit by countless massive meteorite
strikes.
Should these impacts have been powerful enough,
chunks of Earth’s crust would have been
catapulted into space.
As the planet is covered in life, some of
these chunks of Earth rock would have likely
had bacteria hitching a ride.
Should these hardy microbes survive for long
enough -- protected deep inside their rocky
interplanetary vehicle -- could they end up
crashing onto another world, survive the impact
and take up home?
This is hypothesis is known as “lithopanspermia”
and though it’s a highly speculative means
of life hopping from planet to planet, we
do know that rocks have travelled across the
solar system.
For example, Mars meteorites have been found
on Earth -- massive Martian impacts have kicked
pieces of the red planet into space only for
those samples to fall onto Earth, sometimes
thousands of years later.
There’s even been some excitement surrounding
the possibility that fossilized bacteria might
exist within these meteorites, though further
analysis has shown these “fossils” are
actually just mineral deposits.
Another hypothesis called “necropanspermia”
even suggests that for life to spread from
planet to planet the organisms in a meteorite
needn’t be alive when they arrive at their
destination -- their fossilized DNA may create
a template by which organic chemicals can
latch onto, spawning life.
In this case, rocks that have traveled interstellar
distances may seed life in other star systems.
And then there’s an even more “out there”
hypothesis that some advanced alien civilization
seeded protoplanetary disks around young stars
with their own special blend of amino acids
to create cosmic life in their image.
This sci-fi possibility is called “directed
panspermia.”
Although there is currently zero evidence
that panspermia is a “thing” we DO know
that the ingredients for life is everywhere
and it’s possible that the biology that
kick-started life on Earth didn’t, in fact,
originate here.
If you want to find out how we might be CURRENTLY
polluting the solar system with our germs,
check out my video on dirty Mars rovers:
Do you think life as we know it was actually
seeded from space?
Let us know in the comments down below and
don’t forget to subscribe to DNews!